one two years and you've created some
just incredible music out there and when
you have these anniversary it's an
opportunity to kind of reflect on your
journey right so when you think back to
20 years especially being a
self-isolation you kind of get it into
your head a little bit what was it like
for you 20 years ago compared to now
what 20 years ago um first of all I was
young vibrant and I found myself in a
position where I was I was the guy that
was breaking all these barriers in 1993
we did Oh Carolina it was the first
dancehall song in the British chart to
go number one
first ever we did mr. bombastic that was
the first bass I'll record or regular
record to debut at number one in the
British chart first day out we did angel
it wasn't me both of them debuted at
number one also but then the album
debuted at number one where today the
only dancehall diamond album that has
ever sold over 10 million records so at
that point I was so in a space that Wow
all of this is being changed the whole
needle of the genre is being moved by
what I'm doing and what I'm coming up
without in my head to make it move you
know and and that that got me now I'm in
a stage where I think I've just in today
I still had that same fire for some
reason I wanted to create new things but
I am allergic to the status quo I'm
allergic to boredom I'm allergic to
cookie cutting I I want to do something
that is disruptive if you listen North
Carolina there was nothing that sounded
like it and radio when it came out when
if you listened boombastic there was
nothing I rated it said it it sounded
like it when we came it wasn't me we're
in Britney Spears and in st. mode you
know and I came with this song talking
about banging on the bathroom floor I've
always look for disruptive against the
grain type of an idea to come with and
even when I came at four for eight seven
six um would stare it was something that
no one saw coming
I think it was the biggest conversation
was like what
the what the hell is this you know who
thought of this combination this makes
no sense but it made every sense to him
and I and it worked and we you know we
had a grammy-winning Apple we had a not
all that so well we had a torta they
will and it's a testament to me always
coming up with this thing that is
different because that that I think
taking risk and being against the grain
is what moves the needle and if we're
not moving the needle in the genre then
there's no point I don't I don't want to
do what everyone has done I've never
been that guy you know I've always been
the guy that wanted want to be different
you know I'm gonna lead up to this
question because I wasn't sure how to
ask you about this whole thing with
Rihanna making a new album and the
result is miscommunication with it and
what's happening are you going to be
part of this album or hat what is going
to be happening with this I was asked
amar who's the ANR him and I him and I
had a conversation about it and I think
this is where it got out of out of
control is you know I had suggested well
let's let's get into studio and get some
something going and he was like well you
know I want you to send me a couple of
tracks and I see what she's like but I
already know that tons of guys we're
doing records like that so I said to him
I said now I'd rather not do that you
know I guess my choice words at the
point would Deena took it and made it
out of context like all you know she's
real you know it's a he's auditioning
it wasn't an audition I never even had a
conversation where her pertaining
pertaining to that you know I mean it
was literally that I my way of making
records is sitting with people and
really vibing with them and getting that
going and we could do that you know but
to just write a bunch of song and since
everybody was doing that and people
songs are being turned on and my time
and I'm and my argument that I was
making to him was like you know I've
been doing this for you know almost 30
years and I'm still the guy to beat you
know you look at numbers wise there's no
one that has taught me and danced also I
don't care were you going to announce
all too
make a record that's gonna be a
mainstream pop record and and still keep
the authenticity of the core I'm that
guy because I've proven that over and
over and over again but in fairness to
her she doesn't need that because she is
she is that you know but it just went
out of context and people just took what
they went and made different stories and
it was you know dad some fun with it
it's all great but we're good you know
they're good they're gonna come out with
a great album regardless because it's
Rihanna listen it's gonna happen it's
gonna happen it's gonna come out great
um you know and they're just gonna go
through a bunch think she's busy she's
got a lot of time B and I fainted things
on fire you know she's doing her thing
happy for her but you know where I'm
concerned I got a whole bunch of other
projects that I'm working on also and
I'm you know I'm I'm getting ready to
let it out by next year I love that so
while you're in isolation are you making
new music are you doing writing new
lyrics right now the inspiration of my
house I have about a thousand on release
records at least absolutely at least I
mean I mean one of my Studios I have two
rooms in this house I like is there one
song that you absolutely love right now
that you want to release yes it's not my
sign hear it what but I know but it's
it's it's a it's a song from another
artists that I wrote most of it and
co-produced it and really kind of
arranged and put it together
collaboration the whole thing it's such
a monster it's so different when you
hear it it is so left-field it is so in
your face so gets you on the dance floor
it so makes you just like what the f is
this now you can't explain it like that
and not and Korona just stopped me in my
tracks and and I had like a bunch of
missiles to drop right after that and a
lot of this time you want
new artists because I've always been the
guy that do sums and you arse when I had
take for instance when Rick Rock that's
an unknown artist that came on on it
wasn't me
angel is refined and did summertime an
angel
these are unknown unknown artists
recently I didn't I need your love with
mohombi and Faye D which was a top five
record and they're unknowns I always I
don't look at the superstar guy to do it
writ with and if I do it do it with a
superstar guy it's because there's a
report and a camaraderie and and an
energy and a mutual respect while we do
records like that but I do not like oh
let's do a record because this one is
hot and this one is hot I don't
I want it to be the integrity of the
record itself so if the song is there I
don't care if you're an engineer I have
a song here with my engine they're
singing on it
he's not even an artist but the sound
that he came the sound that he came up
with fit the Reg was like oh my god
we'll do that again he was just sitting
here singing sometimes I'd do that again
that is that is crazy
give me that put that on the mic I was
like my time we mixed it and set it up
he was the dominant guy said well I
guess your artist now it's like dude
what are you talking about he looks
nothing but the sound of it is so you
know and we have to chop it up a couple
times to make it you know fit but man
it's it's amazing and so that is what I
go off of the art of it of what
sonically sounds amazing to me yeah
that's what makes you so special your
music is so unique like you said you're
so different in the way you create your
music and really just getting back to
hotshot again and bringing the album
back at I'm making my kids listen to it
right now and say this is what I used to
dance and this is the music that's real
and you know that's that's what makes it
so exciting I mean you're not what's
your kids right now they're in Jamaica
right there in Jamaica right now I got
stuck here in New York it kind of worked
out the sad part is that I'm not with
them but the fact that I'm promoting
this record I'm here and I'm available
to do tons of press and tons of stuff
well if I was in Jamaica I definitely be
you know taking people to horseback
riding
yeah I'll be you know I'd be pretty busy
as when I get on because the minute I
get home I'm back to being that and it's
it's you know I'm doing the drop-offs
and the pickups and you know I'm I'm in
it you know so yeah I'm missing them
hopefully Jamaica will open up and we'll
we'll be able to get back in a week or
so I'm you know I'm keeping my fingers
crossed you know yeah and then hopefully
that's when you get to celebrate this
20th anniversary which is just
spectacular no yeah it really puts a
damper on it but you know I think that
everything this year is going to ship to
2021 2020 is discipline it's a blur in
people's mind we can go to 2021 and
we're gonna resume and it's it's as if
2020 didn't happen